20:14 could safely be called the year of
the game delay but 2015 isn't shaping up
to be a lot better here's a rundown of
all the major games that have been
delayed so far in just the first quarter
of 2015
January brought news that Dragon Ball
xenoverse would be pushed back awake
physical copies of dying light were
delayed in European regions and some
smaller games like The Sims 4 expansion
EA's upcoming PGA Tour title and Dead or
Alive 5 last round wouldn't be meeting
their release deadlines in February GTA
5 for PC got its third delay project
cars and it's seconds delayed and Mortal
Kombat X is last gen editions were
pushed back in March the triple-a game
delay crap really hit the fan Batman
Arkham Knights launch date was
rescheduled for a second time and
homefront the revolution The Legend of
Zelda for Wii U and uncharted 4 were all
delayed until 2016 what on earth is the
point of release dates when they're
becoming notoriously unreliable and is
there a better way for devs and
publishers to advertise when they've got
a game coming out when delays do happen
there is the tendency for fans to be
forgiving of debts they trust and become
forbidden the knowledge that there's a
better product on the way as a result
but there's also a fatigue when we come
to the realization that there's usually
a damn good chance a triple-a game's
release date won't be met the way I see
it is people who make games deal with
release dates in one of three ways the
first is what we've come to expect your
standard marketing hype cycle which may
or may not result in a delay publishers
love having a release date that they can
carefully plot their marketing and
promotional strategy around while it's
great to get some idea of when to expect
an awesome-looking upcoming game ever
release date has to shift it plays havoc
with both the audience's expectations
and the publishers promotional plans
lately the demands of making games for a
new generation of consoles coupled with
high expectations for performer
and polish have resulted in many
developers preferring to play it safe
and extend their development time even
when their publishers have already hyped
to release dates which will probably to
put it plainly unrealistic stitching
release dates could go a couple of
different ways one of which was made
famous by Starcraft and Warcraft
developer Blizzard where developers tell
game is that a game will be out when
it's ready if there's a game being made
from the developer whose games you know
you like sometimes it's enough just to
know that something is coming it's a
strategy being used by a few companies
at the moment while developers setup
react Brad has had some trouble with The
Witcher 3 now on its second delay news
on their other upcoming RPGs cyberpunk
2077 has been very quiet and that's not
necessarily a bad thing
despite being announced before the
witcher 3 cyberpunk 2077 has been in
development out of the public eye over
the last few years aside from some
concept art and the announcements
trailer which closed with coming up when
it's ready we've also seen EA do a
little bit of this concerning Mass
Effect 4 they've told us it's still
coming and showing us some concept arts
but they haven't such a big coming 2015
on it or anything to get our hopes up
eventually these games will have their
release date announced and a big
marketing push will start up but the
idea that these games are happy to be
chugging along under the radar for a
while until they're good to go is better
than saying this year wait no next year
ok the year after
instead gamers are contented to think we
know it's coming just make it good it
might not be what publishers want but
honesty and an unwillingness to wedge a
game into a deadline so early in the dev
process is way more respectable the
third option is a slightly controversial
one it's where Deb's open up the
development process to people through
open betas all services like steams
early access then people get to play the
games as they're being made most of the
debate and controversy surrounding this
one comes from whether or not the devs
are asking for money or they're
technically unfinished products and how
much that aside the decision from some
studios to have a transparent
development process has extraordinary
potential to incorporate player feedback
iron out bug fixes stress test
technology and ideas throughout
development and hopefully create a
better final product subsequently with
that kind of involvement you not only
get to play the game in a far earlier
stage and help make it great you'd also
likely get a better idea of when the
game will be ready for final release
based on its updates and development
progress not all early access games will
hit the mark entirely but there are
several success stories of games that
made their way to an acclaimed full
release including sunless sea wasteland
- dirt stuff and of course minecraft I
used to think of game delays and do you
think gamers would be better off without
release date hype do you think the early
access system works let me know down in
the comments which of the three options
you prefer and I'll catch you again next
week